Speaker 1: Remember that if you want to get on
your nickname in the waiting lobby should be
your name and your town city or town country,
even if it's something other than the United
States where you're calling from. Let's go
next to Joseph from Oregon. Joseph, welcome.
Speaker 5: Hi, David. Thanks for taking
my call. It may be too soon to tell,
but I'm interested in what you think the
results of the midterms could mean for Trump
from a legal perspective, if if conservatives
are suddenly ready to jump ship for DeSantis.
Do you think he could finally see a courtroom?
Speaker 1: I don't think I think the answer is
Trump could see a courtroom. I don't really think
the midterms are the defining factor, though. And
I'll tell you why. Many of the investigations
have nothing to do with the midterms in the
sense that they are state level elections. And
then when it comes to the federal election,
Joe Biden remains the president. I'm sorry, the
federal investigation. Joe Biden remains the
president. Merrick Garland remains the attorney
general. And Merrick Garland made it clear whether
Trump is or isn't running. And whatever happens in
the election, it does not impact how we are going
to carry out the investigation. And I believe
him to a degree anyway. So I actually think that
Trump may think the course of
the midterms and his potential
announcement on Tuesday will change the
course of the investigations. But I don't
believe that they will.
Speaker 5: Awesome book.
Thank you so much for taking my call.
Speaker 1: My pleasure. Great to hear
from you folks. Something about the calls this
week, very, very strong. I have to tell you,
I'm liking it. Let's go next to Steve from
Illinois. Steve, welcome to the program.
Steve. Steve. Hello.
Speaker 4: Sorry. You know, I'm
just. I'm just learning how Dischord works. Yeah.
Speaker 1: So we've got a couple issues. It sounds
like you're using speakerphone. We're also hearing
all of your discord notifications, so we've got a
few different things. What's on your mind today?
Speaker 4: You know what? I really just
wanted to jump in and listen in this
conversation and see how, you know, I was.
Woke up this morning with better news than
I thought I would see. So I really am just
kind of taking in anything I can get my hands
on. And literally, this is my first time ever
using discord, so I really apologize.
Speaker 1: No problem. Steve, listen,
let me put you back on hold so you can continue
listening to the conversation. I really appreciate
that. Let's go. I don't know if this is Austin
from Louisiana or Louisiana. From Austin. Which
which is your name and which is your location?
Speaker 3: I am. My name is Austin.
I am from Louisa, North, Louisiana.
Speaker 1: Got it. Got it. What's on your mind?
Speaker 3: I just wanted to come in and
say that I was very disappointed with my
state. I was really hoping that Gary Chambers
would get a larger amount of the vote. Yeah,
it's very it's very unfortunate what happened
when it did my civic duty for the first time. I
went and voted for the first time. I'm happy about
it, but very not happy with the results. But yeah,
I didn't really expect anything different.
Speaker 1: And for people who may or may not know
the race for Senate in Louisiana, the incumbent
John Kennedy Republican won with about 62% of the
vote. Gary Chambers just under 18% of the vote,
which is certainly a disappointment, but also not
altogether shocking, I have to say. But it also.
Speaker 3: Has to do with the vote being
split between the two big Democratic.
Speaker 1: Yes. The other Democrat had like 12%
or so, right? Yup. Yup. Not so good, but voting
was fine. Did you have long lines? Did you have
any armed people intimidating you or anything?
Speaker 4: No, I live in a I.
Speaker 1: Live in a white suburb, so. Okay.
It was pretty easy for. No risk there. Yeah,
I know. It's horrifying that that that that
explains it. Oh, okay. So it was fine then,
but such is the reality. Unfortunately.
Speaker 3: Unfortunately. All right.
That's all. Thank you.
Speaker 1: All right.
Thanks very much for the call. I appreciate
that. Why don't we go? Why don't we go next
to Wasif from. Is it is it from Bangladesh?
Speaker 3:
Yes. Hello? Can you hear.
Speaker 1: Me? I can hear you fine with. Oh, boy.
Speaker 3: Hello? Can you hear me?
Speaker 1: I can hear you. There is
a very strange sort of digital noise.
I don't know where that's coming from.
Speaker 3: Well, actually, I mean, our, you
know, university dormitory. So, you know,
you'll hear some noise, I guess.
Speaker 1: I gotcha. Is there,
like, a party going on in the background?
Speaker 3: Well, not really. You know,
a lot of people are actually in this dormitory.
That's why, you know, the population is at all.
Speaker 1: Oh, I guess people are studying.
I'm sure it's only studying there. Thank you.
Speaker 3: Yeah, yeah, yeah. Okay. So my question
question is actually related to a rethink US
foreign policy. You could say it also is related
to my country. Okay, that's why I wanted to talk
with you about it. So do you guys know about
the Rohingya crisis? I guess you know, a lot of
Rohingya refugees are in my country now. Yes, yes,
yes. Originally, Rohingya are from the Rakhine
state of Myanmar. Right. So what's happening is
right now my country is actually facing a big
ecological crisis. Do you worry about being a part
of it? And the other reason is the establishment
has some underlings who are actually very corrupt
and they have, you know, done some terrible stuff
with our dollar reserve, basically. So we saw
what happened. What happened is that we are,
you know, very short on dollar reserve and we to
get all our government is asking for, you know,
I have bailouts and, you know, potentially
taking money from China and not you know,
both of them are not really, you know, being,
you know, good enough as they expected it to
be. So we are having a crisis and you know,
the banks are not being able to open new. LC
So the price of let's say of raw materials for,
you know, making medecine and electronics are
going higher. Yeah. So during this situation so
you know, like what we are doing with. So help,
right. So what they're, you know, giving us
solutions that are providing is that they
are going to give us some kind of support, I
think like that. Are they really want to want
us to do something? So so what they are saying is.
Speaker 1: That wasif I hate to interrupt. Wasif,
but we're the audio is a disaster. I'm not super
familiar with what you're asking me and I'm
wondering if there is a question coming. I just
don't know that I'm the right person to answer it.
Speaker 4: Okay. Okay.
Speaker 3: Oh, but, uh. Yeah.
Look, I get it. I'll try to end it as soon
as possible. To end it as soon as possible.
Like one or two sentences. Okay. So you
basically want us to do what? The U.S.
government basically wants us to annex a state
and, you know, go, go, go, go to a war against
Myanmar. That's not what I'm saying. So my
question is it at this point when, you know,
the US is basically calling out Russia for, you
know, annexing all these four different regions,
the Ukraine. Right. And they are doing
the complete opposite. And, you know,
you have to do the same thing that what Russia
is doing right now. Do you think this is a
really good moral ground? Give this kind of news?
Speaker 1: No, you're not. If you're exposing.
Speaker 3: American.
Speaker 1: Foreign policy
is basically what's useful right now. I don't
even know if the things you told me are accurate
representations of what's going on. I just
don't know enough about the situation. But
if it were true, the U.S. is hypocritical on
foreign policy all the time. I just can't I
don't even know if what you're telling me is
the case, because I've just I just don't know
enough about it. Okay. We'll see. Thank you
for the call. Let's take a very quick break.
I don't I just I'm not commenting on what he said
because I don't know if it's true. Like the U.S.
is demanding that Bangladesh do annexation. I just
I've not heard that. I don't know if that's true.
Let's take a quick break. We're going to go
back to the phones in a moment. Stay with us.